foreign
[Music]
okay
welcome everyone to my talk Lira
disrupting full text search industry
with JavaScript
it's a quite of a strong claim I know we
will see if we can get hopefully there
so before we start let me introduce
myself very very quickly
let me see if this is working yes okay
so I'm Michele I'm from Milan in Italy I
work as a senior architect at near form
I'm a Google developer expert and a
Microsoft MVP
and when I talk about full text search
engines I always want to start praising
the god of full text search engines out
there elasticsearch so believe me when I
say that elastic has been the project
that got me into open source I love it I
tried I had the opportunity in my career
to work with the seller with Lucine
directly but elasticsearch it's just on
another level I love it so much
um I had
um an opportunity in the past to work a
bit on Apache you know me contributing
to that project and especially you know
me it's a customer data platform and
it's an open source project of course
that uses elasticsearch as a leader
database in its architecture and okay I
was pretty Junior at the time but when I
saw millions and millions of data coming
through every week I was like
how is that possible Right how can
a software
handle that much data that's incredible
and still be performant so it doesn't
matter if you have like one million
records one billion records
elasticsearch it's always performance so
how how does it do that
um if you're not into Alaska's
elasticsearch just for you to know that
basically it uses Apache leucine just
like solar but provides a nice of good
features on top of it so Lucin it's the
actual full text search library that
performs the search operations but
elasticsearch does a lot on top of it so
it's a restful server so you don't have
to code Java which for me was super good
it's a distributed system which
basically allows you to scale
horizontally your your data sorry your
cluster adding more and more data
without losing any performance it auto
manages sharding for you it takes care
of data consistency and monitoring
cluster management it's awesome so
before proceeding any further let me be
super clear from the beginning
I love elasticsearch and yes I am
talking about something that I built
that it's hopefully competing but I did
that because I wanted to learn more
about how is it possible to have such a
good product not because I didn't like
it I want this to be very clear from the
start
and also
I don't have a computer science degree
and that's the only way I can learn
stuff so what I cannot create I do not
understand and I'm quoting Richard
feyman here I need to build stuff to
understand how things work
so
remember I love elastic but still I had
some some problems with it it's quite
hard to set up and deploy
it's hard to upgrade so if you have like
a security patch to be deployed released
it's not the easiest thing you're gonna
do
and has a big memory footprint so if you
couple that with CPU High CPU
consumption it is very very expensive so
if you're running your own cluster on
AWS Google Cloud platform whatever
it's gonna be very costly and if you're
using the cloud version of course it's
also costly because someone has to
compute that data right
and maybe maybe I was too inexpert and
elasticsearch was a bit too much for me
I know that making simple software is
hard but it's worth trying it so I set
myself a goal I had the unique
opportunity to speak at VR developers in
Berlin this year it's the biggest
developers conference out there it's 8
000 developers coming from all over the
world and I set a goal I want to give a
talk on full text search algorithms data
structures I mean I want to explain to
people how it works so that was my goal
I can work in two modes with goals by
building stuff that's all I need and a
bit of luck I guess because when I
started looking down and going down the
rabbit hole
um with the theory behind full text
search I mean it's not an easy thing and
that's why we all love algolia elastic
melee search Etc all beautiful products
but I definitely wanted to learn more
also the hard truth
you need to study algorithms and data
structures if you want your code to be
that performant we will get there later
on and again not having a computer size
degree myself I don't have like a place
in my mind where I can go and see oh
maybe I studied this algorithm maybe I
seen my professor no I had to actually
start searching for Stuff
and also
when you when you start understanding
how things works you need to choose a
programming language to implement your
algorithms your data structures and of
course I wanted to be a cool guy so I
what ask us no no cool kids don't use
Haskell I wanted to use a cool guy so I
started implementing with rust
too complex no way I have no idea how
I've been programming Haskell for a for
a bit so I thought okay rust might be
easier right no it's not uh but it's
super cool and I'm definitely the
problem here I also started refactoring
everything in golang
same problem I spend my life writing
typescript and JavaScript basically so I
remembered a famous quote from Jeff
Atwood also called the yetwood law he's
the co-founder of stackoverflows that
says an application that can be written
in JavaScript will eventually be written
in JavaScript so why not JavaScript
is the king of programming languages
right
yes
I guess
so yeah and that actually led me to
something that I wasn't expecting when I
started implementing the data structures
required for implementing full text
search such as trees hash Maps inverted
indexes Etc
I made a comparison with rust and golang
which okay maybe weren't so well
optimized of course
but I started thinking that there is no
slow programming languages but just bad
algorithms in data structure design so
that's the first thing I wanna you to
bring home this is an essential part of
our job
and when I started making benchmarks
when I gave my talk people seems to be
impressed with the speed and we will see
benchmarks later on so um eventually my
team had never near form decided to open
source this so we released Lira which is
very nice name especially if you're here
in virath I don't know how to pronounce
but by the way it is nowadays an open
source project so whatever you're gonna
see from now on there's no premium
features there's no there's nothing it's
all open source and it's maintained also
by good Community the good Community has
borne around it because we decided to
code everything from scratch
and we decided to do that without any
dependency for a very specific reason
when we started looking at other
Alternatives such as mini search fuse
lunar which are full text search engines
built in JavaScript which are
exceptional don't get me wrong they are
very good
um we wanted to do something a bit
different
we wanted our
search engine to run literally
everywhere so we had to implement
everything from scratch starting from
the prefix trees inverted indexes B
trees tree Maps the stemming algorithms
and we will get there after
stockwards and support multiple
languages such as Italian English I
don't know um German whatever
and eventually we did it so nowadays
lira is working on every single
JavaScript runtime all the runtimes you
see there plus Graal VM is there anyone
knowing real VM
I'm sorry for you guys
yeah but Rhino if you if you really want
to get fine you know wherever JavaScript
runs Lira runs it's all made for Pure
JavaScript no dependencies at all but
that also opens to a world of
possibilities you know
Lira Works in browsers on ban on Dino
react native node Lambda functions and
net35 functions and cloudflare workers
which are exceptional platforms which
gives us a couple of problems in fact I
was in Berlin again and I met an
engineer that told me you know what it
would be cool if you could run full text
search On The Edge on cloudflare workers
or Netflix functions
um it was very hard but I had you know
um thankfully I worked with Paulo who is
going to give a talk on Wednesday and uh
we were in the hotel Hall together and I
said how can we make it run at the edge
because I hold my beer
that's all he said and we made it so I'm
gonna showcase later but we basically
created a very true shakeable and very
true shakeable and Tiny full text search
engine and let me give you an example of
how it works so you basically want to
create a new variable and you create a
new database you insert a schema so it's
not really schema-less like
elasticsearch for example uh still you
have to Define your schema and your
types for your data which really helps
us in creating the index
when you're gonna deploy it you can
bundle it for example uh if you deploy
it on cloudflare workers you might not
need the insert the insert function or
the create function you just want to
perform search so you just import search
and it's three shakeable you only get
your bundle with the search function in
fact the B
um variable in that case it's nothing
more than a JavaScript object
uh that was a bit surprising to me
because uh JavaScript object every time
you modify the shape of the object gets
slower that's what I thought so that's
why at first we we start implementing
with maps with sets which are known to
be faster you know that Maps but
eventually we discovered that for our
specific use case
objects and arrays were just perfect so
that's another Discovery I made
there are cases most of the times where
new JavaScript features such as Maps
weak Maps or sets are faster in many
cases there are cases where the standard
JavaScript is just fine so always
measure your performances
then you can insert data and this is
blocking the event Loop by the way but
we export an asynchronous function which
is called the insert batch so you
basically as you can see as a first
argument you pass ddb so you actually
mutate the original database by
inserting new data
and then you perform search in that case
we get the database
we perform search for the term if on all
the properties
eventually you can also say okay not on
all the properties just on let's say
quotes So I pass an array including just
the properties I want to perform my
query on and the elapsed property that
you see here 99
can you guess what is it seconds
milliseconds
what sorry
minutes yes hours days now it's actually
micro seconds I wish it was minutes but
no it's actually microseconds so we are
in the millionth of a second area and
you may say yes but you inserted just
for four documents so of course it's
fast for that reason on my machine on M1
Pro MacBook I did a benchmark
and for example I took
whatever I could find on the
international movie database so titles
quotes descriptions cast whatever I put
it into Lira and I said okay let's
search believe through one million
entries and it took just 41 micro
seconds again we are in the millionth of
a second area here
so then I said okay maybe I can try just
on the title property 39 microseconds
which is almost the same then I try with
Criminal Minds you know I'm a big fan of
the show
um with Criminal Minds full text search
engines have to perform two distinct
queries have to perform a query on
criminal a queer on mines then look into
a forward index to see if Minds it's
happening after criminal and give it
more priority Etc so there's a bunch of
stuff to do and it takes just 187
microseconds again so it's really really
performant if you ask me
and nowadays it supports 23 languages so
if you like me don't know nothing about
Dutch for example I wish I I did but I
know nothing about Dutch you don't have
to perform standing operations on Dutch
so when I talk or or Italian I'm Italian
I could do that but the stemming
algorithms are not that easy and I'm
getting there in one moment so basically
when we talk about stemming for example
we refer to that process to take this 10
of an individual token for example we
have lucky
we stand it to luck so we actually
insert the meaning of the word rather
than the entire world of course if
someone puts like lucky we could store
both so you can have like exact match
search or whatever but that's another
story and
with Lira you can always extend whatever
you want so you can given that Lira
basically provides you a series of
indexes you can create your own
searching algorithm if you want you can
create your own stammer and we will get
there how do I create a stammer well if
you're into natural language processing
for example I would recommend you
looking into snowball snowball it's an
open source project created by Martin
Porter which is the author of the porter
summer
sorry which is nothing more than um
um an algorithm a step-by-step algorithm
description that if you follow it will
help you creating stem stamps from words
for example uh search for the longest
amongst the suffixes so if our word ends
with s we just remove it if our word
ends with s s e s we perform that
operation so you know step by step we
can create it and you can have a lot of
fun it's super difficult if you ask me
but it's definitely very funny and just
for giving you an example we have like
consign
which gets them to consign again then we
have consigned the past form which again
we keep the meaning consign so this is
what uh lira is doing for you every
single time you insert a new token and
again you can do it in Italian we
support Italian we support German we
support 23 languages or you create just
your stemming function the goal for lira
is to empower people to learn more about
these algorithms so you can for example
give an each suffix to all of your words
so if you put like hello it becomes
hello ish you know whatever why not
you can do it you can also customize top
words whatever the process is that lira
is running you can always customize that
so the project goals for Lira were to
work on any JavaScript runtimes and we
did it to be as small as possible as
fast as possible and easy to deploy my
thing because that was my original
problem with elastic you know
so the achievements for Lira okay it
works on every JavaScript runtime it's
small and modular it's quite fast if you
ask me can bleed deploy literally
wherever JavaScript runs
and you can also serialize data in
different formats and has a powerful
plugin system
so let me give you an example of a
plugin you might want to persist your
data on disk at a certain point so you
just install your search plug in data
persistence
you create your instance so original
instance in that case you put a couple
of quotes and authors
then use the persist to file function
which is runtime specific that works on
ban and node.js specifically and you
just choose the format by default you
use this message pack which is a form of
serialization format also used by radius
for example so you can use message pack
by default Deepak Json protocol buffers
you can do whatever you want basically
and after you did that on another file
as you can see I'm I'm not like material
I'm not going doing live demos I'm not
at that level yet but
you can restore data from disk and start
performing searches
so now that we know what lira is I
wanted to give you a couple of Target
architectures
for example let's say that you have a
react native application you have a lira
server which performs search actually
and you have your application you can
continue pulling from the server and
when the connection is down you can say
okay I will fall back to the local
database which might be like a sqlite or
an in-memory database or whatever
or and this is more interesting for me
you can create a very okay very
distributed doesn't make sense but a
highly distributed system by deploying
your Lira indexes serialize on S3 you
can notify SNS for example which
rebuilds some lambdas performs some
optimizations and makes it available the
new index to cloudfront so that after
you query something you have a Lambda
running on the Edge Performing the
searches for you and caching everything
so you treat Lira as an immutable that
base and if you need to update remove do
stuff on the index you just do it as a
batch operation every five minutes every
minute whatever
so you can't forget about cluster
management deployment data consistency
AWS takes care of cluster management
when it comes to uh
Lambda functions for example deployment
we will see in a moment data consistency
if we see again
you can deploy to anywhere using nebula
which is still experimental but I have
again I'm not doing a live demo
but I have a recording from my friend
Paolo deploying uh Pokedex to cloudflare
workers for example so let's see
if we have internet connections
so first thing we do we look at the uh
we we basically install uh the nebula
package which is a global npm package we
just use nebula and yeah we write its
name after the Lira constellation and
enable us are Where Stars gets born and
Etc yeah that's crazy okay so if we look
at the files we have we basically have
a data.json file which represents the
data we want to deploy to cloudflare for
example and lira.tml
if we go see the lira.eml file it
basically has a schema which is a schema
definition for our data sharding Auto
truthforce it's not working yet so just
don't use it we will give support as
soon as possible an output output file
so we can decide wherever we want to
deploy to cloudflare which we are going
to do or keep a copy of your data
locally
then the data we actually want to deploy
in that case type Json because we are
taking the data from a Json file and the
Json file itself but we could also say
okay the type is Javascript so we use a
Javascript file exporting an
asynchronous function so that you can
call a database for example and take
asynchronous data and feed Lira and then
deploy it
again uh Target in that case it's
cloudflare could be netlify could be AWS
whatever
configurations uh worker name Pokedex
why not and if you want to run tests
true or false
if we go ahead the Json data we will see
that basically we already
created a Json file with the same schema
as the schema definition for Lira so we
are ready let's clear everything
and run nebula D which stands for deploy
of course
and in just like five seconds
you just deployed a cloudflare worker so
as you can see
at Pokedex which is the name we gave
Paolo thank you again for doing that
which is your cloudflare account for
example.workers.dev and if you use crl
you just run queries on cloudflare so
your congratulations you just deployed
the First full text search engine
capable of running at the edge
so
I don't know where is my mouse oh here
is okay so as I was saying Lira it's
free and open source you just go to
GitHub lyric search at Lira please open
issues please ask for stuff please do
whatever you need to get work start
working with Lira I'll be there to help
you guide you through Target
architectures or I don't know whatever
you need to get this up and running on
your service provider of choice
we also just created like today uh slack
Channel which is called lyric.slack.com
so again if you need anything just ping
me here I will try to answer as soon as
possible
before I finish my talk I'd like to
thank nierform for multiple things first
of all for letting me work in on Lira
for uh letting me being there today uh I
guess you already know and here for me
we are Professional Services Company we
hire in um in U.S
um Europe uh Brazil Canada so if you're
looking for a fully remote job in a
company that knows something about
JavaScript please reach out the boot
um or reach out after the talk so that
was all for me thanks thank you
and I leave my contacts just in case you
want to reach out thank you
[Applause]